[Música]
saben qué es esto
este es un tulipán es una planta bella
la planta hermosa también es tan hermosa
que ocasionó la primera burbuja de la
historia
una plantita como ésta llegó a costar
6.000 florines equivalente en la época a
comprarse un barco comparte 200 cerdos o
todas sus computadoras y todo este
auditorio con todo el evento incluidos
se podría comprar con esto cómo llegamos
a esta locura cómo es posible que algo
así haya pasado pues
para esto tenemos que ir un poco más
atrás tenemos que ir al comienzo de la
historia desde el comienzo de la
historia el ser humano ha basado su
desarrollo en la obtención y explotación
de recursos naturales
mientras más recursos yo tenía más
poderoso era sin embargo esta lógica
tiene una falla ya que los recursos
naturales con el tiempo cambian ya sea
porque disminuyen se acaban o porque
llega una disrupción tecnológica
entonces
cuál es el recurso más valioso
existe un recurso que no es escaso y no
es difícil de conseguir pero sí es un
poco difícil de entender y para esto yo
propongo un ejemplo el es ley que es
también la ahorita son dos países uno
latinoamericano y otro asiático el país
latinoamericano fue en ese tiempo la
octava potencia del mundo comparable con
francia y alemania- y tenía muchísimos
recursos el otro país no existía en el
mapa y no tenía prácticamente nada
este es el día de hoy cómo ha cambiado
la historia verdad
el país latinoamericano
ahora es un país en vías de desarrollo y
el otro país es una potencia usted es
más o menos saben qué países son
i
son argentinas y corea del sur como pasó
eso que ocurrió para que suceda algo así
y lo más importante como es que los
coreanos llegaron a hacer potencias
hay muchos factores que influyeron en
que corea del sur llegue a ser potencia
pero hubo uno que fue fundamental los
coreanos
al no tener recursos para explotar y
sólo tener coreanos invirtieron en su
gente invirtieron a largo plazo en el
recurso más valioso ellos invirtieron el
conocimiento
esta es la estadística de lo desde los
años 70 hasta el día de hoy cuanto en
promedio han invertido corea del sur
versus argentina durante todos esos esos
40 años
corea del sur nunca dejó de invertir en
educación invirtió invirtió e invirtió y
sigue invirtiendo y los resultados se
dan se dieron en 40 años se dieron
resultados que ahora todos prendemos
esto es solamente un índice este es el
este es el último índice de de
innovación
y esto así si entonces
nos hacemos la pregunta si sabemos esto
porque el por qué los por qué nuestros
gobiernos no entienden por qué nosotros
no estamos poniendo en educación y más
que más importante porque latinoamérica
no es reflejo de su educación y aquí
podríamos culpar a todo el mundo
podríamos culpar a los presidentes
políticas económicas todos sin embargo
qué estamos haciendo nosotros para
cambiar esto que estamos haciendo para
marcar la diferencia para marcar la
diferencia no basta ser solo espectador
debemos marcar esa diferencia actuando y
para hacer eso no necesitamos hacer
grandes cosas
quien no conoce un amigo que está
haciendo labor social que no conoce un
amigo que ayuda a niños en las escuelas
que no conoce un amigo nosotros mismos
tenemos ideas hagámoslas y quiero volver
a nuestro amigo el tulipán del comienzo
el tupé nuestra planta muy interesante
porque crece durante todo un año flores
de siete días y luego se marchita y
muere lo mismo está pasando con los
recursos naturales
han estado millones de años en la tierra
nosotros hemos llegado y prácticamente
en siete días los estamos devastando
no pensemos en el corto plazo porque el
corto plazo genera locuras como el
tulipán pensemos en el largo plazo
pensemos en invertir en educación
es el motor del desarrollo y el recurso
más valioso muchas gracias
[Aplausos]